this warns ancestry debacle just keeps
on getting worse check out the latest
cringe-worthy moment as the 2020
Democrat gets grilled about her Native
American heritage there was some report
that said you a Native American on your
Texas ball license and she said you a
Native American on some documents when
you have professor at Harvard like why'd
you do that so it's what I believe you
know that's like I said it's what I
learned for my family when do you find
out when did you find out you weren't
well no it's
I'm not a person of color I'm not a
citizen of a tribe were they any
benefits in it no Boston Globe did a
full investigation it never affected
nothing about my family ever affected
any job I ever got um didn't get a
discount in college now it's kind of
like the original rates with those off a
little bit
white woman pretending to be black oh
this is what I learned from my family Oh
God Martha that was awkward painful and
he also says in another part so what
your family told you you were Native
American look at her she's sitting there
looking like Elizabeth Warren and she
goes yeah it's just an either how long
did you hold on to that it is just so
bizarre is it people just see through
this stuff you know all anybody wants
and it goes from the last segment to
here is for people to be authentic right
and I know that you know everyone talks
about the president he's a P as you know
many people say it's a big wire some
people but you know even the kind people
say he's a big exaggerator right there's
something that is authentic about him
whether you love him or you hate him and
so this kind of stuff just smacks of
that totally uncomfortable feeling when
you feel like somebody is trying to you
know be sort of like part of a protected
class and they're not it's it's and what
made it even more powerful is because
this isn't a professional media
interview this is a relaxed group of
guys on the radio that speak like
regular people and she can get away with
her dances and her talking points if you
do something on a network but you can't
speak honestly about what you did
because you lied and it comes across so
obvious well one Charlamagne the guy's
not just any interview I mean he's
rific I mean that shows the big hit
disarming and she's on I was able to
handle maybe they're not dressed up for
TV but I don't think they're casual
disarming all the Democrats want to get
on that show right now a regular guy
yeah but I think he got to the heart and
soul of the Mary you look at the
questions it's almost bullet point
fashion it you know like hey we think
you have deceived this and so that's an
important point now to the politics of
it it doesn't matter I don't think that
anybody who's going to vote for
Elizabeth Warren is going to say oh I'm
now not going to vote for Liz's barn if
Elizabeth Warren gets the Democratic
nomination and president Trump begins
calling her Pocahontas do you think
that's any different than if any of the
other 23 get the nomination Dana if
you're listening and you're you know
there's a maybe wall in the last day or
two Politico had an article showing that
Elizabeth Warren had started gaining
with african-american voters and she is
in a fight against Bernie Sanders for
second place and yeah I think all of
this matters if you have 24 candidates
and people are shopping around she's the
only one that's put forward very
detailed policy proposals but this has
always been about affirmative action
she's a white woman who listed herself
as a Native American to try to get some
sort of boost in her career in her Ivy
League applications and we know that
that happened because we know that the
university then utilized it for her and
she has tried to figure out a way to
overcome it I don't think she expected
it today
no because it was you she's she's
uncomfortable because it's uncomfortable
to watch it and to know about it
the one thing is it's Donald Trump can
call her Pocahontas and it's like the
his base laughs and it's fine but when
it's coming from somebody else when it's
coming from maybe somebody who might be
on your left or on the Democratic side
that is a different thing and I wonder
if somebody like a Kamala Harris or a
Cory Booker or even Bernie Sanders that
wants to try to figure out a way to get
a leg up well file well actually use
this again do you think that would
happen in the debate I I think that this
is allowing that to happen specifically
I think I think Charlemagne did this
because he has you know he has an
allegiance other another candidate and
he also obviously watches the five
because in October
we gave Liz Warren the Rachel Dolezal
award what am i monologue so Thank You
Charlamagne also he is he's like a laser
beam like I don't think I'd want to be
interviewed by him because he just like
he listened to her her spiel her
patronizing spiel about all of these
redistributionist policies and he just
kind of waited and waited and then he
just one-by-one kicked back the most
common sense questions and and it's just
like it was just that's what made it
painful because it was so it was so on
the level and persistent and it you
could argue that it helps her in the
sense that no one hits her for for for
her policies like everybody focuses on
the the shiny object of Pocahontas and
not the fact that she wants to
redistribute all of your money but the
thing is it it isn't just about the
Pocahontas the persistent poking of
Pocahontas its the fabrication of proof
from laughable data that we had donors
we had covered when she went and she
hired that guy that was all to refute
the Donald Trump stuff that and that was
the bigger lie it wasn't that she went
through she tried to get through college
and get all this free stuff it was that
she also fabricated this kind of story
based on this time but it's not the data
cuz in fact the data backs your point
that she is 0 yeah on the phone with the
guy she said so I am Native presented
but I don't think that's the point I
mean to my mind the amazing thing about
elizabeth warren is despite all of this
she's rising in the post he's number
three in the polls and in fact she has
been eating into bernice and what do you
think do you think that's just because
of the other candidate no I think it's I
have a plan appeal she's the policy wonk
in this field she has burrowed out a
niche for herself as the one who is
speaking to student that for example I
didn't know today I just saw that she
has a website where you can go on in
250,000 of Americans have done this and
see how much of your student debt would
be erased under her plan that's pretty
impressive to talk about that everybody
wants to go back to the DNA problem and
that's where you'd is in deep trouble
you know I'm saying you're the one
that's me to again you always talk about
the small crowds Joe Biden's getting
yeah not Elizabeth Warren she gets big
question she does she does well and this
is going to continue to him
string her she was not admitted that yes
even though I thought I was only a
couple percent Native American I still
claim that was all Native American I
just sent of voters say that this is an
issue for them a Democrat voter it's
about character solver face it's about
character that's like in the previous
climate it's not about race it's about
the character it's about your choices
that you're making and if you have a
choice between twenty four people and
you are having to figure out a way what
who are you gonna cross off your list
like character problems are gonna be one
of them yeah I mean if she can't handle
Sharla man if she goes up against Trump
and has to talk about her Native
American heritage
goodbye